الحرب في تضاريس لا ترحم
معارك الغابات في شرق
أوكرانيا تعني مواجهة هجوم روسي شبه مستمر
يحاول جيش فلاديمير بوتين
اختراق الدفاعات الأوكرانية،
ديميترو هو أحد الذين
يعيقونهم، الوضع نشط للغاية ومتوتر للغاية، كما
يقول، لأن العدو لديه
أكثر من ذلك بكثير  المعدات والقوى البشرية بشكل أساسي
يحاولون كل يوم اقتحام
مواقع جندي روسي ميت
ودبابة مدمرة تظهر مدى اقتراب
الروس، إنها معركة من أجل
البقاء وضد العناصر،
الخندق بارد ورطب ورطب والحرارة الوحيدة
القادمة من الشموع  الجنود يتجمعون
حولهم ويجمعون قوتهم لمواجهة
القوة النارية الروسية الساحقة، يطلقون النار على طائرات ذات نيران مباشرة،
وهي تحلق بشكل أساسي، لديهم كل ما
يقوله
ولكن ربما الأسوأ هو الدبابات عندما تطلق
النار، فأنت لا تسمعها حتى، بل
تسمع طائرة عندما تأتي مع
دبابة أنت بين
يدي الله، نيران المدفعية تمثل تهديدًا آخر هنا
كما اكتشفنا عندما تعرضنا لإطلاق النار أثناء
محاولتنا الوصول إلى
المنطقة بالمركبة، وهذا للأسف
شيء يحدث كثيرًا عندما نعمل هنا في
شرق البلاد
كنا نستعد للتصوير هنا
وفجأة سمعنا
ما يبدو أنه مدفعية منطلقة
ولكن بعد ذلك جاءت قذيفة 100 مني يا رفاق 100
مني 100 مني، نحن نحاول الآن
الخروج من هنا بأمان  قدر
الإمكان، هذا يعني أنه يتعين علينا الحفاظ على
المسافة بين سياراتنا ولكن علينا بالطبع أيضًا
الاستمرار في التحرك طوال
الوقت للتأكد من أننا نستطيع الخروج من
هنا بأمان ونأمل أن يكون
الجميع آمنين، نعتقد أن
طائرة روسية بدون طيار رصدتنا ووجهت
نيران المدفعية ولكن  يمكن لشخصين أن يلعبا هذه
اللعبة نزيري هو طيار أوكراني بدون طيار يوجه
مدافع مدفعية كيف التي تستهدف
المشاة الروس وأيضًا
تشكيلات هجومية مدرعة بما في ذلك دبابات القتال الرئيسية،
ويقول إن نقص الذخيرة يعني أنه يجب عليه
أن يكون
دقيقًا للغاية، وليس سرًا أننا نتضور جوعًا
لقذائف المدفعية.  يقول أننا نحاول العمل
بكفاءة ودقة قدر
الإمكان لضرب القوة النارية للعدو الذي
يحاول الرد بأي طريقة ممكنة في
واحدة من أصعب ساحات القتال في هذه
الحرب